There's a,
there's just a bunch of different ways.
That's the beautiful thing about MMA.
There's a bunch of different ways to do it,
man.
There's Ben Ascaris way just grab ahold une.
Gorilla fuck.
Begged me to the ground is my man to like,
love that dude.
I've known Ben since before he started fighting.
Like he,
he came,
stayed at my house,
my dog bit him and shit.
You had a little Chihuahua.
Beethoven Shit.
Ben.
Yeah,
Ben is my homeboy man.
And I think that,
uh,
I was nervous about him going into UFC because I was thinking it,
you know,
they was going to get him too late.
Yeah.
You know,
because like when he,
you know,
but I still,
I think he's still,
he's in his glory.
He's,
he's never taken any day.
He never takes no damage.
So I was just nervous that they get them too late.
But you know,
Ben has been instrumental and Tyron Woodley's camps.
I mean,
he's just,
his brain is just like,
we think on the same lines.
He's a brilliant guy and he's always sending me books.
Ingestions like he's smarter shit.
Yeah.
But he's also very analytical in his approach.
He's not,
he's not gonna,
you know,
no disrespect to George Grew Gel,
but have George go gel,
abandoned his Jujitsu and just start banging.
Ben's not,
no,
no.
He,
he's never going to do that.
Never happened.
And I liked the way he thinks too.
He's like,
you know,
like he didn't,
he doesn't spend time away from what he's good at.
He stays in that row.
Always coaching.
Constantly wrestling.
Yeah.
He's always coaching kids.
But I mean even even with himself,
like we'll go,
we'll go up there.
Depending China for nothing will go up and Ben will give Tyron how ever many
rounds he needs.
Real.
Yeah.
You know,
most guys,
I got to bring it like two,
three guys and they get time or some work battle,
give them work no matter what.
No matter what kind of shape he's in,
he gives higher and work well.
He was talking about,
you know,
if they do open up that 165 pound division,
which I guess they're talking about because there's so much talent and a
division.
I really think if they moved it to 75 and they had a 65,
75 85,
I think that's better.
Yeah.
And then Ben would fight at 65 cause he doesn't want to,
you know,
fight Tyron,
tell him and tire and a real good friends.
But I like a lot of match ups with him.
I really love the Robbie Lawler fight.
I mean,
I know they pulled off that fight because of the Anaheim card fell apart,
but they're going to fight.
Is it on Brooklyn?
I think they're fighting March 2nd.
Is that what it is?
I think Susan Robinson,
him and Robbie and I felt like they were going to make that a headliner for a
fight night.
I felt like I saw a Robbie's face as a head.
I don't know if that's been solidified.
Just text and ask.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Or Texts Dana.
Um,
it's a,
it's a great matchup though.
That's,
that's where you see where Ben fits in is against worldclass competition.
I mean,
you'll see where he fits in against world class competition or see if Robbie is
done or not.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a great fight for both guys.
Or if Robbie is still a savage.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean I like Robbie taking the time off too.
Yeah.
I think that's important for Robbie.
I mean,
you look at the wars suck.
I went through the Carlos condit fight,
the fucking,
the fucking Rory Macdonald fight.
I mean good.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know who gets out of that unscathed.
Not a single human that's ever lived gets out of that landscape and he needed
that.
He needs time off.
Yeah.
Cause when you get hit like that and just he's a,
but he's a fighter.
When he was screaming in his lip was split open.
I mean it was like a zipper was open.
Yeah.
And scream and I'm interviewing them after the fight and I'm like,
dude,
I can see your teeth.
Like literally see his teeth right through his,
his mouth.
Through his lips.
Oh yeah,
my God.
Yeah.
And he didn't give a fuck.
No.
Stitch it up.
Like,
yeah,
he's,
he's a fighter man.
That's,
that's,
that's the type of guy like,
Hey,
get on that bag.
And those meet at you.
Well,
he used to not even spar,
which is really crazy when he's fighting in Strikeforce.
He wasn't even sparring and I asked him about goes,
well,
I already know how to fight.
Questions are over.
Thank you.
I mean also till you got an a,
but you got to look at it too,
like where he can,
where he comes from,
like them dudes in the Midwest don't got no filter.
You know what I'm saying?
They just,
they was just trying to kick the shit out of each other.
Every spar and practice.
That was every practice,
every practice,
the militants days,
just knocking guys out,
drag him off the floor until they wake up and then bring another guy and then
when you wake up,
bring them back in and bring it back in.
It's really crazy when God's get KOD.
I remember that from boxing gyms.
He'd watched guys get dropped like bunk and then they'd be sparring like 10
minutes later.
Like,
what are you doing?
Oh,
you should be in the hospital.
Do you understand what just happened?
Your brainstem.
See,
I don't like that part of the game.
You know what?
I don't even know if it's even necessary.
It's not necessarily necessary.
It was ignorance because if that guy gets hit again,
he could get like,
do you know Joseph Valtellina after he beat marked a bond in glory,
he won.
He won the title.
He was fucked up for months.
Like he couldn't,
he couldn't have any lights on.
He got to be in a room.
He said that the light from like a charger from a cell phone charger,
that little tiny little light would fuck his head up.
He'd give him headaches.
He had a severe concussion from a fight.
He Won.
He got clipped with a giant knee in that fight and just boom,
send his head back.
And even though he won the fight,
he still was fucked up for a long time afterwards.
So I was looking at use of seat two 35 take shape with two title fights and
three x UFC champs.
So is that on the cards?
It says it's Jones,
Anthony Smith,
who Tyron versus who smile and then ask Cronin Lawler.
Whoo.
That's it.
Here we go.
Is that March 2nd?
Uh,
that's in Vegas,
right?
Yeah.
God Damn.
Pray to the MMA.
God's Keith that card together.
Keep that a,
and then I'll forget a Pedro Munoz and I'm Cody Garbrandt.
Ooh.
Is he on that fight sooner too?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's some fucking card,
right?
Yeah.
Fucking card.